but what would be sort of the
um the the the key you know piece of
data that could be crucial and
discriminating between the possibilities
between all these different models is
there such a thing
yeah
there are particles
I can tell you what particles I think
are left to find
uh in terms of their signatures and it's
funny people always say well what what
Mass what energy which is like the one
bit that you need Quantum field Theory
to do because you have to compute the
radiative corrections and there are a
bunch of things I don't know how to do
yet and maybe I can get there at age 56
maybe I can't
um
but there are certainly particle
predictions that come out of gu that
would immediately say okay well he told
us all these they're they're in that
draft right
um
but that's the dumb version of it the
smart version of it is totally different
it's not a question about oh Theory and
experiment in the scientific method it's
like
look at what is it 26 27 28 parameters
free parameters in the standard model
that's the ugliness that no one wants to
deal with who's gotten involved in
geometric physics they don't want to
take on three generations with a ckm
matrix with random entries and a pmns
matrix and Higgs couplings that
determine the shape of the Mexican hat
potential all that stuff is artificial
with gu what I'm starting to do with gu
is to say oh I I see you didn't get why
I'm claiming there are three generations
that are observed inside of this
geometry you didn't understand why I'm
I'm claiming the Higgs field makes sense
as opposed to as an artificial get out
of jail free card for the for the mass
generation
and
the real question is do you not
understand that the key issue is
naturality what we have is a workable
theory that is extremely unnatural it's
in a natural language there are natural
components the Yang Mills component is
very natural the Dirac component is very
natural the internal quantum numbers
incredibly unnatural the Higgs potential
incredibly unnatural the number of
generations incredibly unnatural the
chirality knowing left from right
incredibly unnatural but gu offers is a
huge number of explanations of why this
unnatural structure is not only natural
but gorgeous
foreign
[Music]